[Música]
estamos llegando por favor a ver un
poquito por este lado pero ya va
llegando arriba
manos arriba
[Música]
hay un millón de madrileños sin médico
entre ellos 200.000 niños en pediatra
han destrozado las urgencias
extrahospitalarias y la equidad en la
atención en las zonas Rurales cada vez
son mayores las dificultades para poder
garantizar una atención digna y de
calidad
[Música]
de los discursos
hoy vamos a grabar hoy sí hoy van a
salir realmente la gente que vamos a
salir a la calle
[Música]
gente como pacientes no tenemos tiempo
para atenderles y es imposible trabajar
así imposible Después les hemos salido
por eso llevamos tanto tiempo yo llevo
más de 2010 desde el día 21 de huelga
perdiendo mucho dinero pero yo lo que
quiero dejarle a mis hijas y a mi nieta
y a mi gente es sanidad no es dinero
Quiero dejarles sanidad
[Música]
a una salud digna y a una salud
universal y exigimos
blindaje de la sanidad pública
[Música]
Cuántas de las personas que están vamos
vamos ya tenemos algunos datos
[Música]